[Music]
i sit at the front and wonder when my
son is going to come home
i always cook good meals and could smell
it before he runs in the gate you could
hear his footprints getting harder to
run in quicker
to get
bowel or
his teeth
[Music]
being the elder sister i was sort of
yeah the role model for him and when
david was born he was
yeah a little fat chubby fella and yeah
i just took to him he was sort of my
little favorite and
after that as he got older he was just
my shadow way wouldn't leave me enough
and he was always there with me
david and mum was
like really close you know that was
everywhere i saw a mum i saw uncle
junior so
like the sibling pact was yeah a really
really really strong one and the love he
had for his mother also and all of us as
cousins you know his really biggest
heart
biggest smile
this is
a memorial of
my son's life story
and how he grew up
this is when he used to get herself
can't see him and cynthia he was a
football player at fort mcquarrie and
played for the sharks
he had a coach and his team was very
good
that was at the time he had diabetes
diagnosed
he was
selling tickets at the time
or his football team to raise monies for
them for t-shirts shorts etc and that's
when he got crook knocking on the door
and he said my joints are going funny i
can't walk
so i just grabbed him and run to the
medical center
it hit him pretty like pretty hard you
know and in the family as well but
they put him on insulin so we had to
have maybe two to three needles a day
and
back then it was the syringes so
being that young and having a syringe
you know poked into it was yeah pretty
daunting for junior and by the time he
was 10 he
yeah knew how to do everything himself
it was like bang get up in the morning
he'd give himself his own needles and
grab his little bum bag and yeah he was
off at the door he was more my big son
than my brother when i left home he left
with me it was like i'm coming sis you
know i'm living with you
i was the one who put him in high school
i tried to keep him on track but
it was yeah peer pressure and just
wanting to do and thinking if he did
this and did that
maybe
he could be normal you know
[Music]
he was in the courtyard they're only
allowed two hour break of 24 hours of
the day
in the jail system is something called a
buy-up system and the buy-up's like your
shop your family sends you money to your
account you get a little bit of freedom
to buy your own snacks to buy your own
toiletries not to just eat jail food
so
because i went and got some extra jets
crackers
you could see this fidgety what was the
next move with screws or nurses or
whatever he knew he was getting locked
down
and inside when you get locked down
you're locked down you're in your room
for how many hours you don't get told
there was a discussion between just a
self-staff
being nurses and doctors on shift that
day and corrective offices about david
eating the biscuits could affect his
diabetes so initially justice self staff
came up with an idea of removing the
biscuits to basically
ensure his safety they say
they tried to disagree like you know
make it that it was essential that they
had to get the biscuits away from david